ich ärgere mich über das versagen
unserer politik bei der hefe der
flutopfer drei monate ist diese
katastrophe jetzt her und immer noch
sind tausende menschen ohne feste
wohnung ohne heizung ohne perspektive
und ich möchte mal drei beispiele nennen
in rheinland pfalz wird bei jedem
wiederaufbau eines hauses darauf
bestanden dass sämtliche
planfeststellungsverfahren eingehalten
werden inklusive aller
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung usw
eine maßnahme die nordrhein westfalen
zum beispiel zur seite geschafft hat
damit es für die menschen wieder
einfacher sein neues haus zu bauen und
da keine bürokratischen hürden sind
rheinland-pfalz ist es nicht so wer im
internet sucht hilfe beantragt den
rheinland pfalz landet auf einer sehr
komplizierten benutzer unfreundlichen
internetseite die am ende auf der man
gar nicht weiterkommt wenn man zum
beispiel seine personalauswahl ist nun
mal nicht eingeben kann sondern viele
leute ihren personalausweis ja schon
verloren man kommt dort einfach nicht
weiter was macht man dann man greift zum
telefon ruft eine behörde an nur
erreicht man dort niemanden der
ministerpräsident zum dreier selber
einräumt es gibt zu wenig sachbearbeiter
in den behörden und die behörden sind
überfordert das heißt wie steuern jetzt
auf einen sehr kalten winter zu ist es
inzwischen schon nähern wir uns den in
den null grad temperaturen viele
menschen vor ort sind verzweifelt und
die politikverdrossenheit steigt das
merken wir wir haben ein beet vor zwei
tagen ein bild stammt ist gemacht vor
ort in ahrweiler dass die menschen uns
berichtet haben ist er schockieren und
ist bleibt hängen bei den menschen vor
ort dass wir eines der reichsten länder
der welt sind aber seiner katastrophe in
unserem eigenen land ob unter scheitern
und zwar an der bürokratie
alexander ich muss sagen ich habe die
schlagzeile heute gesehen bei euch fand
sie sehr sehr hart mir kam frau dreyer
bisher nicht vor wie eine versagerin das
hat mich echt überrascht dass ihr es so
heftig ausdrückt und ich würde auf einen
punkt gerne eingehen du sagst du
sprichst die bürokratie an ich finde wir
gehen manchmal tatsächlich echt nicht
ganz fair mit den politikerinnen und
politikern um denkt an die an die
schnelltests da haben
alle gefordert erstmals muss so einfach
wie möglich sein dann hat unser
gesundheitsminister iren sparen es
wirklich einfach gemacht was ist
passiert es wurden reihenweise betrogen
anbieter haben schnelltests abgerechnet
die sie gar nicht gemacht haben und
hinterher gesagt ja klar also ein
bisschen kontrollieren muss man ja schon
ersparen wollte ist unbürokratisch
machen ein bisschen bürokratie braucht
man glaube ich wenn man staatliche
gelder verteilt oder nicht das problem
ist ich habe das 1997 bin ich schon bei
der oderflut mitbekommen dort wollte man
schnell und unbürokratisch helfen immer
obacht wenn es in deutschland heißt
schnell und unbürokratisch die neider
warten schon hinter der nächsten ecke
und kommen dann hervor man hat geld
verteilt 5000 euro an jeden der es
gerade ganz nötig brauchte und wenig
später kamen dann welche die hatten es
zwei mal bekommen und der nachbar war
sauer dann wurden häuser wieder
aufgebaut schnell und unbürokratisch ja
einer hatte ein altes haus kriegt ein
neues holzhaus auf
dann sagte der nachbar wieder aber das
haus war ja alt von dem warum kriege ich
dich ein neues haus hatte und jetzt
neues aber der hat auch 1 dann musste
kontrolliert werden wer hat welche
flughäfen dann sind wir wieder bei der
bürokratie wir lügen uns in deutschland
gern mal in die tasche wir möchten gerne
alles ist das schnell und unbürokratisch
geschieht dann möchten wir aber auch
dass es sehr sehr gerecht abgerechnet
ist und dann kurz uns hinterher die
bürokratie wieder an uns mal deutsch zu
sagen das ist eigentlich das problem was
wir nicht so richtig gelöst bekommen und
warum ich auch hoch misstrauisch bin
wenn politiker immer von revolutionen
sprechen und entfesselung paketen und
entbürokratisierung es hat bis jetzt
noch nie geklappt
denn das genug getan wurde also war die
bild schlagzeile gerechtfertigt oder hat
man nur drei wirklich vielleicht auch
einfach versagt naja dass das kann ich
von hier aus jetzt nicht bewerten der
punkt ist der bund hat sie ja nun mal
geld zur verfügung stellt die
entscheidende frage ist wie kommt jetzt
das geld bei den menschen an dieses die
dieses geld benötigen und wir haben das
zum beispiel nur auf ein westfalen
gesehen dort hat die landesregierung ja
sehr früh gesagt wir brauchen einen
sogenannten flut beauftragten also einer
der quasi in der verwaltung sehr konkret
für die organisation zuständig ist so
und so wie ich das jetzt mitbekommen
habe ist ja das problem der
landesregierung in rheinland-pfalz oder
des landes ist ja ein
organisationsproblem zunächst einmal es
gibt offensichtlich nicht genügend
beamte auf landesebene oder auch auf
kommunaler ebene das muss ja
letztendlich auch von den städten und
gemeinden umgesetzt werden das scheint
das problem zu sein ich glaube aber
schon dass man auch das mit mit der
bundesebene zusammen organisieren kann
das muss natürlich schnell gehen und ich
kann verstehen dass die menschen vor ort
außerordentlich frustriert sind ja klar
in der konkreten situation aber
letztendlich am ende des tages ist es
doch eine frage der organisation ist es
nicht der früher eine frage dass die
mittel nicht vorhanden es ist halt
verheerend für das
gesellschaftliche zusammenleben und das
den verdruss dem mann den man dort
schafft wenn man bilder sieht von
politikern die mit großen versprechungen
und gefolgt von kameras die durch die
länder ziehen und dann bleiben die leute
zu rücken afrika was ist bei euch
angekommen oder gern außer großen
versprechungen nichts ich bin sicher
dass jeder wirklich bemüht sich das
beste zu tun niemand niemand ist dort
mutwillig lässt die leute im stich aber
ich habe wirklich das gefühl
die politiker haben sich sehr weit aus
dem fenster gelehnt sind alle vor ort
liga ist und alle helfer vor ort
angereist sofort mit ihren gummistiefeln
und gefolgt von ganzen tross von kameras
und haben unkomplizierte hilfe
versprochen und dennree gmbh ist wenn
wir bild jetzt nach drei monaten
hingehen oder den menschen hat sie mich
fragen hören wir halt sehr viele klagen
und die klagen sind sehr konkret jetzt
solche offenbar sehr genau angeschaut
auf seite eins riesengeschichte gemacht
eine frage die mich interessieren würde
weil ihr so tief im thema offenbar drin
sein wert sein besser gemacht wie es in
nrw gelaufen also nrw gibt es zum
beispiel ist deswegen habe ich vorhin
dieses beispiel genannt beim konkret bei
der dann wieder errichten von dem
verloren gegangen oder beschädigten haus
ist ganz normal in deutschland und muss
ein planfeststellungsverfahren machen
das dauert ewig wer wie ist der abstand
zur straße die runde 100
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung an dass
das das hat nordrhein westfalen gesehen
dass das ein problem ist dass da ein
bürokratischer stau ist und hat gesagt
also für den vier neu für alle neubauten
gelten als neuer wieder errichtungen und
nicht als neubauten dh die hälfte des
bürokratischen krams ist schon mal vom
tisch das wäre etwas konkretes aus
rheinland-pfalz einfach sich eine
scheibe abschneiden könnte von nordrhein
westfalen kein problem erkannt und haben
dort versucht die bürokratie abzubauen
also ist es wirklich wichtig dass
politiker wir hätten wir hätten die
politiker hätten wir auch dort hingehen
können und sagen können wir können nicht
wir können wenig für euch tun ihr müsst
jetzt nachbarschaftlich zusammenhalt
aber die politiker sind dort hingegangen
sagt wir helfen euch wir helfen nicht
unkompliziert und dann weiß was je 300
der spieler und weiß dass fischers
alexander malu dreyer wurde ja während
des wahlkampfs gefeiert als helden ihr
bild mit angela merke sie war die starke
frau armin laschet wurde wegen seinem
lachen wirklich also noch mehr fertig
gemacht hätte meine menschenwürde
interveniert und jetzt bist du hier und
reden darüber wie gut ist nrw läuft da
muss man sich doch mal wieder fragen wo
wer wird eigentlich diskutiert die heute
vielleicht weniger über das lachen und
mehr über maßnahmen diskutiert werden
sollen das finde ich ist ein punktestand
augenblicklichen lagen sollte heute
abend bei wenn nrw so viel besser das
macht als rheinland pfalz da muss man
sich dass er langsamer fragen oder nicht
die halbe sogar noch einen schritt
weiter gehen und ich würde sagen die
flut kann auch wenn es denn etwas
positives gibt dazu führen dass man mal
überdenkt welche regelungswut
tatsächlich bei solchen bauprojekten an
den tag gelegt wird wir haben das bei
kfw förderkredite dass die flächen maße
sehr stark begrenzt sind die anzahl der
fenster und eine küche darf nicht größer
als ein bestimmtes das ist sehr sehr
kompliziert und sehr verriegelt die
statik füllt ganze leitz ordner bei
einem ganz normalen einfamilienhaus
selbst wenn es ein standard bau ist der
schon 1000 mal gebaut worden ist man
könnte wirklich mal überlegen was man
davon alles braucht und was man nicht
braucht es gibt ganz einfache formeln
traufhöhe abstand zum nachbarn fertig
man muss die statik selbstverständlich
auge behalten wenn ich heute
zusammenbrechen hat auch keiner was
davon aber es muss nicht so minutiös
geregelt sein wie es heute ist das sagen
hat das gefühl nein ich wollte also ich
kann das ja bestätigen ich meine wenn
man sich mit baudezernenten unterhält
man weiß wer in deutschland wenn die
öffentliche hand baut gibt es in der
regel immer ärger und hinterher sind
auch die kosten anders als man das
ursprünglich geplant hat das ist das ist
leider so aber ich wollte nur sagen wenn
die politiker damals nicht zur in so
einem moment nicht bei gibt dabei wären
dann hätte ja auch hätte man sie auch
kritisiert nach dem motto hier findet
eine katastrophe statt wo bleibt die
politik wo bleibt der landesvater wo
bleibt die landesmutter das ist ja die
erwartungshaltung war ja schon da dass
die politik dann erscheint und ein
gesicht zeigt also ich glaube das kann
man ja da kann man keinen vorwurf
gegenüber der politik
so fiel bei arminia schütz lachen
geredet hätten wir die zeit und da mag
ich auch der presse jetzt gerade und
auch selbst auch mir ich habe auch über
das lager in mattiertem vorwurf hätten
wir vielleicht die zeit lieber nutzen
sollte man zuschauen okay aber wie läuft
es in nrw wie läuft es dort anstatt
wirklich nur auslöser besucher
eigentlich meine holzhaus regelfall
strings
faustregel blei aber sprich nichts was
du nicht halten kannst die die
ankündigung der politik waren halt sehr
vollmundig und dann gehen wir als bild
drei monate später hin zu den leuten
denen alles voll witzig blaue vom himmel
versprochen wurde und die haben
plötzlich sehr sehr konkrete probleme
sitze halten
das grundproblem ist dass bei diesen
besuchen im flutgebiet geht es um das
zeigen von empathie das ist völlig
problemlos wenn es dann um die
abrechnung geht was denn wirklich am
ende geleistet ist es sehr viel
komplizierter und viele kommen eben dann
auch zum gesicht zeigen ins flutgebiet
sind dann wieder weg und danach
übernimmt wieder die klassische
verwaltung natürlich das muss man
versuchen irgendwie in den griff zu
kriegen wir versprechen aber bei bild
das wir dran bleiben also wir haben dort
auch ein büro vor ort eingerichtet wird
julian reicht unser chefredakteur war
schon das zweite mal vor ort also wir
versprechen ihnen bild bleibt dran
[Musik]